you're dropping the hammer on the team
keep dropping the hammer don't give him
a chance to get it together but anyway
we thank you Nick nurse for that gaff
because it get we it's funny we were
paying attention all night to the NBA
Finals game to come up with some idea
for a draft based upon how it all went
and that's what we settled on coaching
decisions that backfired Chris so and
I've I have six great ones today
meaning I'm covered in the event that
you take three of them go ahead you have
two choices
heads or tails rig coin toss let's see
if you make it two days in a row I feel
like I got eight great ones so you're
going down and I'm going to go heads
today it's over you know do you want to
start calling them every now and then
you tried to go ahead guys for the first
year work together just we I know you're
not nice now so just nice no I've never
been nice okay I mean come on do we know
what this is do I mean do I really got
to explain this the worst coaching
sessions decisions that backfired hmm
let me think hmm Super Bowl xlix there
was this really good running football
team hmm they had a running back that
had the nickname of beast quake for two
of the runs eat at for his career I mean
he was the biggest beast in the league
it was called beast mode and there on
the one freakin yard line getting ready
to win the Super Bowl with 26 left
seconds left and a timeout remaining and
we decided to throw a pick play that
we've done a number of times throughout
the year like Bill Belichick hasn't
studied film it wasn't prepared for that
instead of giving it to Marshawn Lynch
who had just mashed it up the middle for
like a 6 or 7 yard gain and one of the
head scratchers of all time took a
chance away from the Seattle Seahawks to
really maybe become a dynasty and got
New England back going into their second
dynasty but to me that's that's just I
mean hands down the number one draft
over drop mic see you later yeah all
because you called heads and you got
heads in the rig coin toss but that yeah
obviously that's the first pick in this
one and and you think about the effect
that had on the Seahawks I mean it took
them how many years to get over it they
had
is in that locker room that we're never
gonna get over it no I remember Pete
Carroll like did every show that he
could he did the Today Show cuz cuz and
my theory at the time was he doesn't
have access to his players for the next
three months so he's hoping that family
members see him on the Today Show and
say all Pete feels really bad don't be
upset Richard Sherman don't be upset
Bruce Irvin don't be upset Marshawn
Lynch give the guy the benefit of the
doubt it was horrendous what they had to
go through but they brought it on
themselves made a decision that
definitely backfired that would have
been my first pick yeah that doesn't
give me a whole lot of solace because I
didn't win the coin toss alright my
first pick since you took the best one
this one's still pretty good it's not
from a Super Bowl but it's an indication
of why this guy may never coach in a
Super Bowl 2011 month of December the
Cowboys taking on the Arizona Cardinals
the Cowboys driving down the field in an
effort to kick the game-winning field
goal and the clock is ticking and they
spiked the ball so they have eight
seconds left to kick the game-winning
field goal and as they're lining up to
kick the game-winning field goal a
timeout is called but it's not called by
the Cardinals all no this timeout was
called by Jason Garrett to ice his own
kick first kick was good but oh you've
been iced by your own coach and then of
course they lined up to kick it again
and the next time around
after the kicker was iced by his own
coach the second try is no Cardinals
would go on to win and somehow Jason
Garrett is still the coach of the
Cowboys to this very day oh gosh you
know what I totally forgot that one
that's a good good call by you but what
made you where did you find that out
where did you look that up and find that
one I remember it I remember this one on
Mary Anne that's what happens yeah
here's what happens when I'm falling
asleep right especially when we have a
late draft like this and I haven't had a
chance to really think about it like I'm
falling sick and I try to remember these
and it's like I was falling asleep it's
like all wait am I got four I got five I
got six now the challenge is will I
remember them in the morning yeah
and I almost forgot them but I remember
I remember that one because that was all
at the time where there was this
narrative the Jason Garrett Kant macro
and micro a game right he can't do the
play calling while also looking at the
bigger issues like do I go for it do I
call the timeout to ice my kicker or
don't I and and eventually he ended up
giving up the play calling duties cuz he
couldn't do both he couldn't walk and
chew gum at the same time all right
you're up around two all right round two
gosh there's some good ones out here I
don't know what to go with here but I
think I have to go with this I mean
first of all it's a very important play
to the Sims family I mean maybe Phil
Simms never goes to the New York Giants
without this play right here the miracle
at the Meadowlands okay I gotta take
this one it's just it's a huge moment in
the history of the NFL but the New York
Giants at Giants Stadium 1978 up 17 to
12 20 seconds left in the football game
and there's no time outs with the
Philadelphia Eagles who were on defense
kneel on the freakin ball and call it a
day instead they decide to run the ball
off a left tackle Joe passar chick
fumbles the ball and the ball bounces
around and our man Herman Edwards picks
it up runs into the end zone Eagles win
the game in a game they had no business
winning I still don't know the story of
that I don't really get that one how the
hell do you not Neal the ball in that
situation I'll never understand it I
don't feel like I've ever got a great
explanation for it I'm not sure that
kneeling the ball and victory formation
was quite as popular then it became very
popular after that I don't know how
common it was I have to go back and
research that but I know definitely
after that happened that's when I saw
everyone you're taking the knee you're
not taking any chances in those garbage
time plays because the worst thing that
can happen sometimes does happen well
you know what you've inspired me to go
off the board by using that word miracle
and I'm thinking of questionable
coaching decisions it just happened last
year it happened in Miami
the Miami miracle the questionable
decision by coach Bill Belichick to put
Rob Gronkowski limber as timber out on
the field to
to play defense and unfortunately he
eventually had to play defense as Kenyan
Drake was running toward the end zone
there was no chance Rob Gronkowski was
going to track him down they were ready
for a Hail Mary and the Hail Mary did
not happen and after a lateral or -
there goes Drake and there goes gros
Gronk's got the angle that's like Herman
Munster out there trying to play defense
sorry brought you the best tight end of
all time you picked the right side of
the ball defense not your forte so
that's a coaching decision the idea was
you want those guys there for when they
throw the ball to the end zone Bill
Belichick who rarely gets it wrong got
it wrong they didn't throw it to the end
zone they went with the the lateral fire
drill and it worked because they ended
up getting isolation on Gronk and Gronk
he was he had 20 yards he was
embarrassing it looked like me out there
you're right I think the decision I bet
that it's weird is I just I guess I
wouldn't have put him back there I
understand why he was back there's back
there for the Hail Mary like you said
you're spot on but they were so far away
that I probably would have challenged
and gone I don't think Ryan Tannehill
can reach from here so I'm not gonna
play the Hail Mary him and put a
defender on the field so that would be
my two cents but gosh okay Bill
Belichick is allowed to mess up one
situation he's got 9 million correct and
proves it to us all the time man there's
so many good ones on the board here and
I'm even gonna because because I'm a
good guy I'm gonna throw my brain out
here right on live air you might I mean
I don't know if I go with the benching
of Malcolm Butler here I mean you talk
about decisions gone bad and they
Philadelphia Eagles Superbowl I'm going
after Belichick again I I'm thinking
about it I don't I want to spread the
wealth somewhere so I'm also thinking
about Mike Ditka giving the ball to
refrigerator Perry for a touchdown in
Super Bowl 20 instead of giving it to
the greatest player in franchise history
and Walter Payton that's on the list
I mean tell our man Tony Dungy kicking
in the opening kickoff the Devin Hester
that's on my list I think ultimately
though I am gonna go with Ditka giving
the ball to refrigerator Perry instead
of why what's wrong with that go ahead
go ahead finish making your case I don't
want I don't want I don't want to
disturb you while you're in the process
of taking your hand off the checkers
I'm trying to spread wealth around the
league here to me that's an ultimate
blunder I mean it's a coaching decision
gone bad yeah that kept him from winning
the Super Bowl oh it didn't it just
solidified a jerk move who was up
obviously someone ambered with the
attention and oh gosh I got to give the
ball to refrigerator Perry that he
couldn't sit there and think wait the
guy that has carried the franchise for
the last ten years basically here has
not got a ball we should get him a
touchdown so to me that was like mean
bad horrible and I know in Mike Ditka
feels guilty about it to this day so I
certainly am NOT piling on but I am kind
of piling on and I just think because of
the magnitude of one of the greatest
players of all time and Walter prayed
and that's why I'm putting it there I
know it's not necessarily an EXO no game
decision or game defining decision kind
of that way I can't believe you left
Malcolm Butler I didn't want to go left
him on the side when but when Belichick
does it when he has those rare gaffes
and also on my list remember when he
went for on fourth and one in 2009 again
sir bolts they've been up 17 points in
the fourth quarter and went for at
fourth and one he pulled the Barry
Switzer move fourth and one in your own
end and didn't get it because he was
concerned that if they but they punted
the ball that they weren't gonna be able
to stop Peyton Manning anyway but
Belichick putting Malcolm Butler on the
sidelines in Super Bowl 52 for the
entire game having that half hour of
half-time in that game and not realizing
we need this guy out there to try to
slow down this offense we cannot stop
yeah they could be working on number
eight this year they could have capped
three in a row yes if Bella and I don't
care what it was I don't care what he
did
you have legacies on the line here man
and you don't put Malcolm Butler in the
game and look here's the thing it's not
about the guy's ability because clothes
Belichick friend Mike Vrabel gave
Malcolm Butler a pile of money to join
the Titans last year so now you for
leaving that one on the board because
who cares the Bears still won the Super
Bowl I mean yeah it was a slap in the
face of Walter Payton but it's not a
coaching decision that backfires
in the sense that you lose the game Bill
Belichick there's that that arrogance
that you see from time to time he
thought they'd win the game without
Malcolm Butler he thought he was gonna
send him
message he sent the message but he ended
up not winning me yeah he's a little
follower I know I wanted to spread the
walls I didn't want to have New England
be half listen who cares it fits the
theme of the day coaching decisions that
backfired you made a decision that
backfired and I overcame the fact that
the rigged coin toss gave you the clear
cut number one well Mia were you even
you weren't even you didn't even think
of Malcolm Butler either I think I gave
that to you I don't think it was on your
list and because I that's why that's why
when the other guy still has picks left
you don't me ender and muse about all
the things you could choose we're gonna
do right all the ones that we didn't
pick we can talk about in the next
segment and I would like to tell me some
other good ideas that maybe I would have
used no I hadn't thought a Malcolm
Butler but it doesn't matter
I picked Malcolm Butler all right quick
recap of the draft of the coaching
decisions all-time that backfired Chris
Simms won the first pick and the rig
coin toss Pete Carroll throwing the ball
at the goal line in Super Bowl xlix
that's clearly the top pick the miracle
at the Meadowlands that was a good pool
by you Mike Ditka gives the ball to
refrigerator Perry in Super Bowl 20 that
didn't backfire they still won the call
Mike Ditka a jerk for you I like Mike
Ditka 2019 Mike Ditka in 1985 was a jerk
right Cowboys icing there Jason can I
finish the recap please Jason Garrett
icing his own kicker was my first pick
then the Miami miracle with Rob
Gronkowski playing defense for the
Patriots and then Malcom Butler not
playing defense for the Patriots in
Super Bowl 50 - I can't believe I won
this one Chris and you gave your
executive decision backfired because you
started meandering about all the guys
you could pick and you forgot that I
still had a big nose I thank you yet I
did not care I was trying to have a
conversation live on air that was going
on in my own brain okay and I try to
spread the wealth on these drafts I
didn't want to see a patriot logo on
there at four out of the six things so
iCare iCare I want to give all the
cities love all the fans love okay i all
love I told you I almost picked Tony
Dungy kicking the ball the Devin Hester
to start that say one hai day one I
still backfired
he was the greatest kick returner ever
on the first play the city boy and he
tells the story that they were
determined to not kick - Devin Hester
then the night before he said all we
can't do it exactly in - right so that's
a backfire - even though I know they won
but that decision backfired
I was we were just talking about Joe
Gibbs on one of the pods Joe Gibbs
throwing that screen pass at the end of
the half when they're playing the
Raiders Wyrick right they ran the play
early on in the season in their first
matchup and went for like a 70 yard
touchdown they did it again it gets
intercepted and they go into the half 21
3 I thought about that and then read
write 88 right Brian Sipe throwing that
interception when they were in field
goal position 1980 divisional playoff or
1971 divisional playoff game against the
Raiders right was it 71 that gave me
Haiti I got my years but jumbled up
right that's that's a that's a huge gap
there's too many things I read I said 80
at first then I went to 71 then I went
dated that one and Wade Phillips
benching Doug Flutie for Doug Johnson
that was another one that was on my list
how about Marty mourning wag when he was
the coach of the Lions in 2002 winning
the toss in overtime that backfired and
this one really wasn't a coaching
decision per se just more coaching
incompetence but it deserves to be
mentioned right a 2009 NFC Championship
game the Vikings driving for the win in
regulation before Brett Favre threw the
body across the ball across his body and
had it picked off by Tracy Porter Brad
Childress coming out of a timeout had 12
guys in the hole and they got flagged
for five yards pushing them yeah out out
or at least on the fringes of field goal
range and killing that drive before the
throw the desperation throw by Favre
that sent the game to overtime and the
Saints won so thanks for nothing they're
chilly
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports